[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to Planet
coaster and welcome back to aerobats of
Arabia in today's episode I'm going to
be working on a dark ride section of the
coaster and also some other interior
stuff a little bit of exits and gift
shop action as well which is kind of
unusual for me you guys might know that
I'm not a big interior guy
I just don't think I'm very good at it
typically and it's not always my
favorite thing to work on but with this
coaster I wanted to give it a full kind
of indoor kind of Outdoor Experience a
little bit like the Flying Dutchman at
the afterlink or something like that I'm
just a really big fan of roller coasters
that manage to combine Dark Ride
sections indoor roller coaster sections
and outdoor roller coaster sections all
together in one big immersive experience
and with this ride it also kind of fits
the story that the whole ride is based
on
as I've said before it's based on the
story of the caliph stork and I've tried
to avoid spoilers in some of my
commentary which kind of made me think
today why am I even doing this it's a
story that's almost 200 years old I know
people sometimes spoil movies from 20
years ago because they're like you
should have seen it at this point and
honestly it's just a fairy tale but um
I'm still gonna speak about it in very
loose terms because I do think it makes
sense to at least save a little bit of
the story for later sections when we're
gonna work on more Dark Ride sections
not to mention the final video because
hopefully this is going to be a coaster
that'll be able to kind of tell the
story at least a little bit through the
right experience and I want to figure
out how to really do that in the end and
it's it's fun to also leave some story
elements for later episodes
to talk about if you don't know the
story yet so I'm only gonna keep talking
about those parts of the story which I
relevant in specific videos and today
we're working on one of the last
sections of the story so basically we
have some we have the caliph and his
vizier and they're magically transformed
into storks and they forgot the word
which they need to say to transform back
into humans
um and yeah basically they've been
bamboozled by an evil wizard that wanted
to steal the kingdom it's kind of what
it boils down to also I guess he wanted
to steal the caliphate but you get what
I mean and at some point near the end of
the story they're very sad and they end
up in an old ruined castle and that is
what I'm going to be building here and
the rest of the story continues in a
very exciting way that I'll talk about
later but for now it's important to know
that the way that the coaster goes is
kind of based on the story so we start
off with an in a city at some point they
start flying about and that's when we
enter the exterior parts of the coaster
and now we enter the last dark right
part of the coaster where we explore
these old castle ruins and from an
in-game perspective I think it's a it's
a really fun theme to tackle especially
in a dark ride section because it's a
theme that we have so many useful theme
makers toolkit items for especially the
ones made by Blackman Shadow so a huge
shout out to him
these ruined pieces are all from a big
collection that he's made a while ago
and the textures are just really nice
it's quite realistic almost too
realistic because generally most items
in Planet coaster have a sort of
cartoony Style
but this really suits the theme that I'm
going for plus the idea with aerobats of
Arabia was always to try and use as much
theme Maker's toolkit as I can that's
also kind of why I chose to go for the
themes that I chose to go for because I
know that for many of these themes there
are many the makers toolkit items
available and especially the trees being
in a kind of tropical environment means
that we can stick to all those amazing
theme makers toolkit palm trees and we
don't have to deal too much with the
in-game trees which will probably ruin
the immersion a little bit because I
think Frontier only really got trees
together very well once they started
making Planet 2 and we're a little bit
too late with that unfortunately
so the basic layout of this dark right
section is that we have both coasters
doing kind of a helix in opposite
directions so this is where the coaster
split again and then you'll be able to
meet your counterpart going the other
way around which I think is gonna result
in some fun interaction I was trying to
get the coasters to come as close
together as they can be without running
into any issues that you might actually
hurt each other
um and I think it's just gonna be fun to
have that timing moment where you're
both going through the curve and you can
see your opponents so to speak
um going through their side this is also
where they start diverging a little bit
in terms of how the layout is going to
go red is a little bit faster has more
speed purple is a little bit less
intense in that sense but it does have
an inversion assortive the track inverts
but of course it doesn't do it that
quickly that the cars will rotate as
well so you'll always stay upright this
is still a family coaster in the end and
but you do have a some slight Variety in
what these layouts do
which I guess also means that if you do
ever visit this park you know I decided
to build two coasters to make the
capacity a little bit better which is
kind of like Max and Moritz in the
afterlink thinking about it it's it's a
little bit of a tried and and tested
technique but at the same time if you're
really a die-hard fan and especially a
coaster Enthusiast you're gonna have to
do both of these anyway and I think in
that case they should deliver at least a
different enough experience where you
can think of which one's your favorite
and they could appeal to different
kind of people who are into different
kinds of stuff a little bit like Windows
fear and force and Fantasia land which
are also dueling spinning coasters but
with enough different elements that I
know most people have
um very strong opinions about which one
they prefer and I think those are the
good kind of dueling coasters
um so yeah some of the other scenery it
does contain some in-game foliage but
also lots of rubble to make the rock
work-ish kinds of elements as you can
see there are just so many pieces that
you can make a ruined building with so
many Rubble pieces both from the theme
makers toolkit set but also from in-game
Adventure Pack and also lots of Vine
pieces and stuff like that and when it
comes to Vines my favorite choice is
often actually goes go for the rose
Vines I think they are they're supposed
to be flowers but if you make the
flowers green and try to get them in
exactly the same shade of green as The
Greenery of the plant is you can
actually make some pretty good Vines
that actually have a really 3d effect
whereas the standard vines in Planet
coaster are just a 2d texture so it's
not quite as useful and especially with
these very detailed 3D ruined Pieces by
Blackman Shadow from the theme makers
toolkit I think this kind of push works
a lot better now for the supports as you
can see I was messing around a little
bit with just standard simple supports
but then I realized they kind of ruined
the immersion of going through this
ruined structure so instead I figured
why not make some supports that are kind
of dressed up and look like they could
be something like fallen down pillars
from this Castle so in the end that's
what I ended up doing and I think it
works a little bit better you could very
well imagine that there would be a real
steel supports inside these Stone
decorations
they're kind of disguises in a way but I
think it works a lot better to do it
this way than to go with the standard
support structure
I'm also building all of this without an
exact idea of what the building around
this is going to look like I just wanted
to make sure that I got this centerpiece
right and that the tracks look good
enough
but one thing that I already noticed is
that it's kind of hard to do a dark ride
section Justice in this case it's
already kind of harder with roller
coasters because your camera at least
when you're doing a POV is fixed to the
front so you can't exactly look to the
side and see what kind of scenes are
happening there especially on Fast
sections like this because you don't
have a lot of time so all in all I'm
building this scene in such a way that I
think it would look pretty cool for some
off-right shots and maybe if you're
looking around in the coaster but mostly
it's going by way too quickly to really
think about what you're going through
and really take a look around you if
you're on the coaster so I would say
this whole Dark Ride section is more
about the vibe than particularly any
details so I'm not working too much on
the details I think the general look of
the area the ruined atmosphere and the
lighting are gonna be some of the most
important parts of all of this and the
more detailed Dark Ride sections are
going to be at the very end at the very
and the very beginning of the coaster
when we have the slower sections that
are supposed to ease you in and out of
the story a little bit more not to
mention that doing Dark Ride sections
with this coaster type in particular
is kind of a ridiculous idea and
sometimes I'm kicking myself or even
coming up with it because these things
have such a huge hitbox that it makes
building buildings around them a little
bit annoying as well and even looking
back at this dark right section this is
a huge building within Planet coaster it
doesn't really seem that bad but you
know looking at it in terms of dark
rides you could fit almost three rooms
of of a regular smaller type Dark Ride
into this one building and this is only
one curve this is only for like 10
seconds of ride time so all of that is
really just because the hitboxes are
enormous and even for that larger curve
on the purple coaster you know it's not
entirely banked so it just goes to the
side by like a meter and a half
um so it just makes the building so much
bigger on all sides and yeah this is
just the coaster section and we still
have a bunch of sections to go so it was
a little bit ambitious to do this in a
dark ride sort of way to begin with but
oh well I think it's fun to do anyway
now for this section uh looking back I'm
not entirely sure why I decided to put
some catwalks in here but I figured
realistically I can put some catwalks in
here and it would be a pretty difficult
place to evacuate people if something
did go wrong and this is kind of a the
deepest valley in the whole layout so it
could Valley here very well so I decided
to add some catwalks in there just to
make evacuating a little bit easier but
I still have to figure out how I'm gonna
make those catwalks go anywhere same
goes for the purple coaster which
doesn't have them at all but there I was
figuring you know there could always be
some things that I could install I
haven't really done anything with this
yet in game but perhaps that could even
be some kind of real at the in the roof
where you could lower a small wagon and
get people out of the cars it's just
that this is a very difficult to
evacuate coaster and ways to even
evacuate people are always something
that's kind of on the back of my mind
when I'm making uh coasters and yeah
this coaster type just makes that very
strange I also remember riding the the
one free fly in real life in Summerland
and
also realizing that there were catwalks
and some of the parts like the brakes
and the lift Hill but other than that I
really wasn't sure how that thing was
going to be evacuated in any way
um so yeah it's this is an awesome
coaster type don't get me wrong but it's
it's things like these that also make me
wonder or or make me think that it kind
of does make sense that there's only one
of these in real life because it's just
a little bit a little bit too nuts
almost
um but that's the fun of it you know
it's a it's a coast type that's so rare
and so unique
and still really cool and I think
thinking of it actually I'm looking at
the layouts for tranon which is the one
in scouter Summerland
and it does look like they strategically
placed some sort of catwalks in some of
the lower points but
maybe the layout does keep in mind which
places it can Valley in and which places
it's not going to value in but yeah it's
it's a complex thing I would love to see
that thing uh be evacuated somehow I
think that would be one of the weirdest
evacuation credits you can get in the
theme park world
anyway I'm finishing up this whole
ruined Castle structure by placing these
large brick walls on all the sides as
well because I wanted to at least make
it look like you could be inside a huge
abandoned castle the exact architecture
of this again I'm not entirely sure how
it's going to work in real life but do
keep in mind that most of these walls
you're not going to see a lot of it's
mostly going to be very dark only the
center part and some of the parts around
the tracks are going to be lit up and I
want to bring as little as 10 attention
as possible to the roof to the walls on
the side especially because the roof is
going to be a simple standard Dark Ride
roof I'm not going to theme that I want
to keep it realistically ugly and at the
same time not draw too much attention to
it anyway that's it for the Dark Ride
section so now we're moving on to
another part of the video I figured the
Dark Ride section alone wouldn't really
deserve its own video so I'm slapping
this other interior building on the
video as well
which is kind of fun I I don't do
interiors that much but this came out uh
pretty good I think I'm I'm decently
happy with it and it's the exit path to
the uh from The Coasters and uh the gift
shop as well now when I was building
this layout when I was building this
building uh for the coaster as well I
wasn't really thinking of the exit and
the entrance and especially the queue
line and the exit paths and how they
were going to match up was gonna be a
pretty difficult task because we have as
you can see three different exit paths
here because we have three different
places that people have to enter these
two coasters from because again the
layouts are kind of complex it's it's
almost like making two ring riders in a
row and
um yeah it's
it's just something that's a little bit
more uh complex than most exit path
structures and I wasn't even thinking of
where to place this stuff So eventually
I figured I had enough space here to
work something in and still have space
left between the coaster and the plaza
for a merch shop which is you know in
terms of realism something that you
always want to add at the exit of your
coaster just so people have to walk
through the merch shop and they could
make some impulsive purchases that's
just how it works gonna make some money
but the challenge here was that we are
pretty low uh below the coasters and
there's not a lot of space to work with
so I couldn't exactly make large uh
fancy arches like I've done for some
other parts of the building
but I also think it kind of works this
way
um thematically you know the station
building itself is a large Palace or at
least within the station where you enter
and exit the coaster it looks like the
interior of a large Palace never mind
that the front facade where you enter
the queue line Looks like
um a mosque because you know these are
just things that the queue line is so
confusing in terms of its layout and
shape anyway that I doubt most people
are gonna know which way is left and
right once they enter the station kind
of in a you know Phantom manner hide the
actual layout of the building kind of
way so yeah you feel like you're in a
palace and then once you leave the
coaster you walk down into these Cellars
and I imagine they're kind of like the
basement of this Palace you know you're
entering the the back door sections and
it's not all as fancy as it is up in the
station still a little bit fancy we've
got some pillars some intro lighting I
still want to make it look nice but it
does look like the basement so that's
the general vibe that we're going for
here and then in the basement there is
this pretty shop hiding where suddenly
you enter this very small Bazaar and
there's all kinds of stuff to buy and
you know there's also the the space
where you can buy photos from the photo
moments in the ride speaking of which I
did already install the booth where you
can buy your photos it's gonna be uh
right here with the trusty Archer of
course to figure out what my dimensions
are gonna have to be but I still don't
know exactly where I'm actually going to
place the camera that's going to take
these pictures realistically speaking
it's gonna have to be in the dark ride
section but I'm not sure what kind of
perspective and location is very handy
so ideas about that are very welcome I'm
gonna return to the coaster at a later
stage because in the next few episodes
I'm gonna work a little bit more on the
theming first
but um it's something that I'm still
trying to brainstorm about so yeah
anyway moving on to the interior of the
shop here I decided to take my ceiling
decoration from the other store and just
plop it into here because it fits
perfectly and I think it makes the
ceiling look a little bit nicer and then
I added this kind of
um Compass like decoration for the
ground floor tiles
right underneath it so we've got a
little symmetrical thing going on and
then we also have a nice place to place
a chandelier and make this whole thing
look a little bit more fancy than the
rest of the basement that we're in
um so lots of tiles here now these tiles
are they have a kind of glossy texture
that I'm not a really big fan of I think
Outdoors they tend to look a little bit
too light and reflective
especially compared to some of the other
path textures that I'm using but I think
for an indoor environment they work
perfectly so I decided to use those
there and then behind the counter for
the photos there's just a much simpler
wall because you know this is where the
Dark Ride building starts encroaching on
the store so it just barely fits but I'm
very happy that it does just barely fit
because that's realistically what you're
looking for with your dark ride building
you don't want your dark ride building
to end up being too large and take too
much space to make the whole thing
because that would just look a bit
unrealistic I always find it fun to look
at theme parks on Google Maps especially
these days because many theme parks in
the world are now available in 3D
and it's always fun to look at the dark
rides and see how large their Dark Ride
buildings actually are and I think some
of the most impressive dark rides are
the ones that manage to make a small
building look much bigger than you
thought it was and it's also fun to look
at those buildings and try to figure out
what the layout of the ride itself is
looking at them and I think this is a
similar case like that you know with the
planet coaster park you're always
looking from well mostly looking from an
aerial perspective and having a dark
ride building that's realistically sized
for for a real life theme park in
general I think adds to that sense of
realism as well
so yeah everything's kind of cramped in
here but I think that's a good thing as
well now of course we have to put loads
of Planters everywhere because we have
to make this look nice and tidy and uh
thankfully this outdoor uh window slash
indoor basements uh pillar look I think
doesn't Clash too much so we do have a
different wall on this side
um but it adds some variety I think to
the interiors and doesn't make it look
bad necessarily then I made some custom
lamps here and with the lighting you can
really see this place coming to life I
think and realistically
it's also how I'm going to shoot most of
these indoor sections because I make
these indoor Parts with Daylights
because it's just a little bit easier
but the final product and what they're
actually gonna look like to people
visiting the park will of course be in
Planet coaster nights because that's
when you can see what it looks like with
the lights on and without you know the
sun shining through the roof which
doesn't exist yet so um finally I need
to add some merchandise of course and
thankfully we have lots of theme makers
to get items with clothes and books and
posters and games and all kinds of
doodads and gizmos and who do hickeys
and whatnot
um to uh to place in here and
um yeah there's not much of a Rhyme or
Reason to any of this but just plopping
down lots of stuff and that's it for
this episode hope you guys enjoyed this
little look into some interiors and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign